hello everyone and welcome to the
conclusion of the match magnus carlsen
versus pragnanda it is uh game three of
the ftx crypto cup round seven and uh
well so far if you've been following
what's been happening games have been
extremely wild but both of the games
that we've shown ended in the draw
however that is uh quite over now uh it
is magnus carlson with white versus
pragnanda with black it is game three
let's see what happened in this one so
magnus now opens with knight to f3 and
when this happens you know that it's
gonna get serious he's throwing out his
wheelchair championship preparation
and uh of course uh
prague better be ready for this with
pawn to d5 d4 knight to f6 and now pawn
to c4 we have e6 and g3 magnus goes for
the catalan opening uh d captures on c4
and now bishop the g2 we have bishop to
d7 croc showing that he is more than
ready as this is only the fifth most
popular continuation queen to c2 and now
pawn to c5 by prague and here uh there
is actually a famous game uh from the uh
1983 candidates tournament between uh
garry kasparov and victor korchnoy where
kasparov just castled and he defeated
cortney but here magnus goes for queen
captures and c4 it is considered uh best
uh uh you know to uh uh based on today's
standards uh bishop the c6 by prague and
d cap prison c5 we have knight bd7
bishop to e3 and now we have bishop to
d5 chasing away the queen and there are
some games where queen to a4 was played
queen to b for his normal queen to seat
using a move but the move magnus plays
queen to c1 is a new move so it is now
as of move 10 that we have a completely
new game uh we have knights the g4
prague goes after the dark square bishop
here and bishop g5 attacks the queen we
have queen to a5 check and now queen to
c3
magnus offers a queen trade proxies all
right but we trade on c5 so queen
captures we have castles by magnus and
now uh bishop back to c6 it's a it's a
position where you could play a lot of
moves like rook c8 h6 bishop to a7 queen
b6 moving the queen out of the way but
prague decides to go for bishop to c6
and says all right if you trade i get to
develop my bishop for free so h31st
chasing away the knight knight g to e5
and now we have knight captures knight
captures and rook to d1 so neither
player wants to really trade and help
the other one develop bishop captures
ng2 uh king captures and now queen to c6
with check magnus blocks this with pawn
to f3 and only now proctrates queens
queen captures knight captures and now
pawn to a6 we have knight to a4
a very nice move magnus is going after
this b6 square and
okay the rook is on a8 but if you
imagine if the rook wasn't there rook to
d8 would be checkmate so always
something to always keep in mind uh and
here b5 although it seems like a move
you want to play because once this
knight lands on b6 uh the b7 pawn will
not be able to move forward uh if b5
right away then knight b6 is uh
basically winning for white point being
that after the rook moves rook ac1 is a
free move for white of course you can
never capture this will always be
checkmate so once f6 is played bishop
back to e3 defends the knight white
complete development and those rooks are
just monsters on cnb file so it would be
very very hard for a frog to play this
so of course he goes for bishop to e7
counters the dark square bishop and
magnus goes back bishop f4 we have
knight to c6 and now knight to b6 making
it a bit hard uh for
uh prague to develop his pieces but now
rook to d8 is possible as both the
knight and
bishop are keeping around the d8 square
and the bishop to c7 this is how magnus
forces the trade rook captures on the
one rook captures and bishop to c5 now
we have knight to c8 just because uh he
can and now pawn to f6 we have bishop to
b6 now offering a trade of bishops and
prague finally gets the castle we have
bishop captain c5 rook captures in c8
and now a very nice rook to d6 by magnus
going after the e6 pawn we have rooked
the d8 process all right you capture on
e6 then i get the active d2 square and
magnus actually allows this so rook
captures an e6 rook to d2 and now bishop
to a3 defending both the b2 and the e2
pawns but now comes king to f7 attacks
the rook rook to e4 and now we have pawn
to b5 you could also consider f5 right
away but prague first goes b5 king to f2
and now he goes pawn to f5 but now this
is actually good for magnus rook to f4
now with ideas of g4 or just capturing
the pawn if the king remains on f7 so
king to e6 and now king to e1 attacking
the black rook so rook back to d8 uh
here a very nice move to consider was g5
for prague point being that if rook
captures an f5 king captures on f5 and
king captures on d2 uh there's the the
there's the pawn to b4 move that traps
the bishop it still would be a bit
better for magnus for example captures
captures as you do have uh six pawns
prague only has three for example a3
knight goes somewhere and then king to
d3 b4 and so on so it would be white who
would be pushing for the win here
but it was definitely in the position
prague goes back rook to d8 and now
magnus strikes with g4 uh now you could
trade right away but prague goes for g5
instead it's sort of a delayed trade g
captures an f5 with king f6 and with the
rook still hanging rook to e4 king
captures on f5 and now bishop to c5 we
have rook to d5 attacking the bishop and
now bishop back to e3 we have knight to
e5 and now pawn to h4 by magnus this is
how he wants to
grab hold of
all the pawns on the king side h6 with h
captures h captures and now rook to d4
nicely
nicely offering a rook trade also
possible with bishop to d4 it's a very
tricky move and also just uh straight
out of winning for magnus now just um
threatening to win the knight because he
is up a pawn so if he trades everything
he is winning
but then let's say knight to c6 bishop
to c3 and now you are controlling all of
the squares that the knight can use to
get into the game if the knight jumps
you trade uh especially if it's a square
like this then you just trade everything
and if something like rook to c5 king f2
you start bringing the king into the
game and
black is just paralyzed so uh instead we
have rook to d4 by magnus now proc
traits captures captures and not knights
the c6 and now magnus will have to prove
that he can win this uh being up upon
it's a bishop against knight so yeah if
you remember uh for example what stein
said he said if you give him an end game
and he he's up upon that he will be
winning that end game so we've learned a
lot about endgame since the era of
stanis but he wasn't all that wrong but
uh
there are some games that you actually
can't save being upon down uh there are
some games of course you can save being
two pawns down uh but uh when it's a one
a one minor piece against another minor
piece usually it's you know you either
can or can't so bishop back to c3 we
have pawn to g for now now trying to
trade down as much as possible king to
f2 g captures king captures now magnus
gets the past e pawn and king to e6 we
have king to e4 and now we have knight
back to b8 so now
prague will have to figure out how to
hold this uh position we have king to d4
knights to d7 with bishop to b4 and now
knight to b6 we have pawn to b3 taking
way the a4 and b and c for squares from
the uh dark knight here and the knight
to d5 bishop back to d2 controlling the
knight now preparing to push e4 knight
to f6 and now pawn to e4 e5 is also
coming knights the d7 and bishop to b4
so now
magnus basically has to figure out how
to
get across these squares with the king
if he can touch any of those squares
with the king he is very very much
closer to winning so here knight to f6
you have to allow something but at least
now you prevent king c5 as the pawn here
is hanging so magnus advances it forward
knight to d5 now
attacking the bishop bishop to d6 and
now pawn to b4 now there is no good way
to prevent king to c5 uh so pawn to b4
we have king to c for end point the a5
now defending the b for pawn king to b5
and now prague goes for the trade knight
to c3 check king captures knight
captures and now we have king to a4 and
this is a crucial move by magnus because
if you don't play this if you just
capture here then knight to c1 and
prague gets a draw king a4 just knight
captures on b3 of course king captures
and king captures and e5 will be a draw
by insufficient material so after knight
captures on a2 we have king to a4 uh
putting uh prague in in in two swung now
there is no good move now knight to c1
is pointless because just king captures
the bishop of course will keep defending
the pawn so instead after king a4 king
to d5 by prague but now king to b5 we
have king to e6 and now king the c4
came to f5 and now king to d5 chasing
away the the king from the e6 square
knight to c3 check king to c6 now king
to e6 and the king to c5 again attacking
the pawn here so knight the 82 and now
king to b5 and now uh
of course you you can't keep an eye on
everything king to d5 is played and now
king the a4 king back to e6 and now just
the bishop captures on b4
but now it's much different because now
if king captures for example on e5 uh
bishop to d2 and the knight is trapped
you know when the bishop and knight are
part two squares that the bishop
controls all of the squares that the
knight can go to and especially if the
knight is on the edge of the board it's
very very easy to trap the knight so
this is what magnus spots so knights the
c1 instead but now just bishop to d6
defending the pawn here king to d5 now
comes b4 and the two pawns are now just
much too
powerful we have knight to d3 uh pawn to
b5 knight to b to check king a5 knight
to c for chuck king to a6 and he was in
this position on move 72 that
praganananda resigned the game as there
is nothing more to be done here uh
once you make a move king is just b6 and
there's no stopping the pawn you have to
give up the knight and then of course
this is winning uh as uh well
it's a central pawn if it was uh for
example uh maybe on the edge of the
board and there's a light where you have
a dark square bishop and the king is
like all the way on h1 then we can talk
about uh a draw but of course this is
completely winning so yeah that's what
happened in game three so first two
games ended in a draw and game three
ends by magnus winning and now we are
going to discuss what happened in game
four so now uh this is also rapid prague
has one last chance to get back into the
match now he can no longer win the match
in rapids as you remember we discussed
that as um
he's uh
two too far along behind magnus uh as
you can see uh by going into day seven
magnus had 15 points pragnanda had 13
points so he needed a win in the rapid
section in order to overtake magnus
which is now impossible uh now if uh
prague wins they will only go into tie
breaks and then magnus will also gain a
point so magnus is definitely the winner
of the tournament but prague can still
win the match so let's see what happened
uh
in this one prague has the white pieces
and yeah sorry i forgot to mention this
i will show here uh game three game four
and also the last game of the uh of the
blitz section uh so let's uh check out
what happened
in this one so here prague opened with
d4 we have e6 by magnus the horowitz
defense pawn to c4 and the bishop to b4
with check this is known as the keras
defense bishop to d2 by prague and now
bishop captures on d2 queen captures and
now pawn to f5 this is how magnus plans
on holding
his position uh we have uh knights to c3
and knight to f6 we have ponta e3 and d6
and already as of move 6 we have a
completely new game which is definitely
something that prague can use to his
advantage if he can outplay magnus in
new territory so bishop to d3 pawn to e5
uh immediately going for the center we
have knight the g to e2 and now pawn to
c5 sort of baiting proc to goes uh d5
and prague does play this but now he
allows pawn to e4 and later in an
interview prague said that he was very
very upset about losing the previous
game like that and that he just uh got
into a really really bad uh position
very early in the game but what can you
do bishop back to c2 knight beat to d7
and now bishop to a4 not allowing the
knights to go to e5 because once magnus
advanced this pawn to e4 he of course
wants to put his knight here then the
knight comes to d3 and
wow uh so here uh uh magnus castles now
knight to e5 is possible and prague of
course goes for bishop captures and d7
we have knight captures and now pawn to
h4 yeah he has to go for it there's no
more waiting knights to e5 we have b3
and now knight the d3 with check it was
pointless to try and stop this king the
f1 and now magnus goes for a queen to f6
as uh the the white king still hasn't
castled the rook on a1 is undefended so
this knight can never move so knights
the f4 by prague and now we have pawn to
b5 by magnus something proc said later
in an interview that he was very
surprised to see this uh i think uh as
as magnus already won uh at the event
he's definitely the winner of the ftx
crypto cup he wanted to
finish the the tournament sort of with a
bang and but if you want to play this
seriously you play knight captures on f4
the knight captures on f4 mess up
white's pawn structure and then play b5
making knight capture is impossible
because of queen captures here and after
c captures on b5 now white has a double
def pawn double b pawn and of course
this should not be a problem for magnus
but he played b5 and now prague just
happily captures on d3 e captures and
now c captures on b5 and now this is
much different the king side here isn't
ruined and this b5 pawn could
potentially be very strong so a6 magnus
challenges it rook to d1 now and a
captures on b5 we have knight captures
and now pawn to f4 magnus going for the
attack e captures and now bishop to g4
uh prague defense all right pawn to f3
we have bishop to f5 now defending the
past d3 pawn and king to f2 uh prague
finding all the correct moves rook f38
and now knight to c3 uh we have pawn to
h pawn to h5 stopping white spawn to h5
and now rook d to e1 offering a rook
trade magnus trades here and now we have
rook captures on e1 sort of uh giving up
the h for pawn but the problem is if
prague plays queen captures here then
magnus has a win with the queen d4 check
king to f1 let's say d to attack the
queen bishop d3 coming that's it there's
no no there's no defending this so after
rook captures on e1 we have rook capture
sunny one queen captures on h4 with
check and now king to g1 so it looks
scary but uh proc's position is actually
perfectly fine here we have queen back
to f6 by magnus now comes knight to b5
and now pawn to h4 magnus continues
pushing further but pragna starts
pushing his pass pawn as well we have
pawn to c4 trying to weaken the a4 pawn
and now b captures on c4 we have rook
captures and c on a4 and now rook to c1
uh we have king to h7 magnus bringing
his king to safety
before continuing to push and now king
to h2 we have bishop the g6 and now we
have rooked the c3 uh and now rook to a2
a wonderful move by magnus forcing uh
queen captures the rook here and then
queen captures on f4 becomes possible
and prague really has no choice uh if
you just move the queen somewhere then
the rook controls the d2 square and you
can just start pushing your pawn so
queen captures an a2 queen captures an
f4 with check king the h1 and knob pawn
to d2 and it seems like magnus has won
this but luckily for uh for prague he
finds the only uh defensive idea uh
queen to a1 uh and now after queen to e5
there is a move it's not an easy one to
spot but it's the only one that saves
the position for prague so feel free to
pause the video and try to find this uh
incredible idea while i give you a
couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on parting with your
rook and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show it is rook to c1 this
is the only way we prevent queen to e1
check and then d1 queen so rook to c1 we
have to give back something d captures
on c1 magnus even brought a rook into
the game he didn't even bother bringing
you a queen because it comes with check
queen captures on c1 and now bishop to
d3 and uh it's uh not easy but with this
bishop to d3 move prague now actually
gets some winning chances he plays queen
to d2 attacks the bishop and now the
problem is if bishop captures uh on c4
queen to c to check just picks up the
bishop so magnus uh missed this for some
reason so he has to go back bishop to f5
but now proc plays the incredible queen
to g5 and now how can magnus defend
against this uh he plays h3 which seems
like a
like a great idea but prague finds the
incredible knight captures on d6 and now
of course if queen captures and d6 then
bishop here falls away to check so h
capture sanji to check and now the very
important king to g1 i hope none of you
were considering actually capturing the
pawn because then bishop h3 check and
you lose your queen
so after h captures on g2 checking g1
now comes queen to e1 with czech king
captures and now queen to e2 check king
to g3 queen to e5 with check and now
queen to f2 magnus plays queen to bat a
b2 with check king to g1 now comes queen
to d for check king to g2 and queen to b
to check but now king the h1 and now
of course delivering one more check
along the back rank will result in queen
to g1 so no more checks for you so here
bishop back to d3 and now we have queen
to e3 uh again uh putting putting
pressure on the bishop so bishop to f1
now magnus with one last idea
checkmating the white king and g2 but
not just queen to g1 we have queen to c1
putting uh pressure on that uh on that c
pawn but it doesn't really matter here
knight to f5 by prague and it was in
this position on move 51 that magnus
carlsen resigned the game as there are
simply too many threats uh you've heard
of the uh principle of two weaknesses
well this is the principle of three
weaknesses because now uh checkmate is
being threatened and once magnus defends
this for example queen a1 which is the
only move that defends checkmate and the
defense the bishop here uh there's the
one weakness there's the second weakness
and there's of course the third weakness
our good friend the d pawn d6 d7 d8
brings a queen into the game so magnus
cannot keep an eye on everything so
prague bounces back he forces blitz tie
breaks and this is what happened in the
next one so in the first game of the
blitz uh magnus blundered pretty badly
very very early on in the game and
prague took the lead and this is the
final game of the blitz section that we
will be showing so uh you know to stay
true to the after the values of the
channel we will uh change the a little
later on on the on the robot i almost
said on the bird because uh you know in
the past there was a bird there
so let me just quickly uh update this
there we go all right so now we are in
the blitz section and uh
it's really a wild one so it's prague
with the white pieces and he opens with
d4 uh we are not going to deeply analyze
this as its blitz and the magnus goes
for the modern or for the robot defense
with g6 with e4 and bishop to g7 knight
to f3 pawn to d6 and bishop to c4 we
have knight to f6 and queen to e2 now by
prague knights to c6 and now pawn to h3
and now prague only needs a draw uh to
win the match he he will not be winning
the event magnus already won the ftx
crypto cup uh but you know beating
magnus in a match that's kind of the
dream uh we have pawn to e5 and now d
captures knight captures and knight
capture spawn capture so of course this
is uh uh almost
almost impossible to lose for white it's
just a superior position we have castles
uh by both players so castles by prague
castles by magnus and rook to d1 now
claiming the d file queen e7 and now
pawn to b3
we have rook to d8 offering a trade of
rooks and now there are some games where
bishop to a3 was played but here we have
rook capture 78 and it is now as of move
12 that we have a completely new game so
let's see how magnus handles this queen
captures on d8
uh knight to c3 and now pawn to c6 we
have pawn to a4 stopping b5 and now
queen to e8 uh defending the pawn here
we have bishop to e3 and now bishop to
e6 also now the queen can capture if the
bishop captures so rook to d1 and now
bishop to f8 trying to activate his
pieces a bit more bishop characters we
have queen captures and rook to d3
preparing uh our queen to d1 then you
control the d file basically for the
rest of the game a6 and now queen to d1
so magnus really did not achieve all
that much from the opening uh especially
in a position where he desperately needs
a win so here we have bishop to b4 f3
now uh solidifying here defending the e4
pawn and now queen back to e7 we have
king to h2 frog just slowly improving
the position and pawn to b5 now we have
knight a2 attacking the bishop bishop to
c5 and prague again very happily trades
captures captures we have captures
captures and rook to d8 with check now
we have rook captures queen captures
with check king g7 and queen back to d2
proc trades off uh
the entire board and now says all right
this is a draw let's call it a day you
win the event i win the match uh but
magnus is not so quick uh you have many
dark square weaknesses around your king
so let's go knight stage five knights
the b4 uh and the now knight to f4 so it
could be uh very very ugly if prague if
prague's queen moves then let's say
queen f2 queen g2 checkmate so you have
to be very very careful but at least
prague doesn't have to push for anything
he's very happy with just the draw so c3
and now pawn to h5 by magnus with h4 not
allowing the pawn to come any further
knight to e6 now magnus has to figure
out a different way how he's going to
push for the win knight d3 attacks the
queen queen d6 and now queen to e3
improving at least a little bit we have
pawn to c5 and now knight to f2 we have
knight to f4
and now proc plays g3 chases away the
knight 96 and now queen to d3 here
prague offers a queen trade but magnus
can't really agree to this if he's to
have any winning chances whatsoever so
king g2 queen to a5 and now we have pawn
the c4 by prague and here magnus plays
b4 and he says all right now your
position is much much worse as i'm going
to play queen to a2 i'm going to have
constant pressure on the b3 pawn the
knight is coming to d4 that will also
put pressure on the b3 pawn and on the
f3 pawn so you have given me a little
bit a a little something here so queen
d5 by prague queen to a1 now by magnus
and now how do you defend against all of
these threats for example if you if you
try queen back to d3 to prevent um the
queen from infiltrating it's impossible
just queen for example the b2 or queen
to a2 and now uh what you play knight is
coming here put the putting pressure
here putting pressure on b3 something
will
fall here so here knights to d3 by
prague and now queen to a to check king
h3 magnus picks up the b3 pawn and
prague picks up the e5 pawn we have
queen to b1 and now kink the h2 not
allowing queen to h1 checkmate that
would be very scary you have to uh
be mindful of the g4 square being
guarded by the pawn so king h2 prague
spots this and now queen to be to check
king h3 and now pawn to b3 magnus starts
advancing his past pawn knight to d3
attacks the queen queen to c3 and now
pawn to f4 prague now starts pushing the
pawns we have pawn to b2 and now uh
prague plays uh
uh
uh knight captures on b2 and this is now
very very scary uh because now i i don't
want to spoil it for you but feel free
to pause the video and to win the game
for magnus while i give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting that
product has blundered a mate in four and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show it is knight captures on f4
with check now the king has no squares
only square is king to h2 the knight the
pawn covers g4 knight covers g2 so king
h2 only square and of course this is
impossible because the queen uh uh
prevents the pawn from capturing some
king h2 queen captures or queen to c2
it's much cooler if you don't capture
the knight this comes with check and now
it doesn't matter king ju1 or king to h1
whatever you play queen to g2 will be
checkmate however luckily for prague
magnus misses this he doesn't spot the
force checkmate
instead he plays queen captures on b2 he
is now up a piece but prague plays pawn
to f5 with queen to a1 by magnus again
magnus going for this queen to h1
checkmate king to g2 now comes g
captures on f5 e captures on f5 queen to
b2 check king the h3 and magnus plays
queen to c1 incredible as it is he plays
uh sort of the only move that doesn't
win him the game uh as uh he's still
planning on delivering queen to h1
checkmate but prox queen is guarding the
h1 square so that is that is very weird
so f captures on e6 uh probably just
wins back the piece for free and there
is no checkmate the queen covers h1 so
uh a really really weird stuff happening
with magnus ever since uh ever since
that game three where he defeated prague
where he completely outplayed him in the
end game uh he won the event and it
seems like he just started uh missing
everything so f captures an e6 and now
uh uh without capturing this for example
you can still get a draw here queen to
f1 check you just you know check the
king forever and that's it but magnus
played f captures on e6 i think he was
already very much disgusted with himself
and now prague just played queen to e5
with check and he was in this position
on move 52 that magnus cross and
resigned the game and with it the the
entire match
uh so yeah now like i said magnus wins
the ftx crypto cup pragananda wins his
match against magnus and the final
standings are magnus first place uh
alvareza uh or rather uh pregnant uh
second place in dollars a third place
they have the same amount of points but
i believe prague has better additional
criteria
uh so here you resign because whatever
you play all of these pawns will just
fall with checks so there's no point in
continuing to play this for example king
of faith queen captures on c5 with
checking f7 queen captures an h5 with
check and so on now prague will just
have too many pawns and uh
that's it
so truly truly a wonderful wonderful
match uh brilliant stuff by prague
getting the two draws then magnus taking
a lead in the match and then prague
bounces back forces tie breaks and then
just crushes magnus in the tiebreaks
truly incredible stuff uh but it is uh
in the end magnus carlsen who wins the
event he i i think he he was very happy
about winning the event but i think he
was more sad about losing this match uh
to pragnanda than um
he was happy about actually winning the
event uh but we will know more uh sorry
about covering only this match but it
was the one everyone was interested in
as you know no one else could could take
the take the win so if you have any of
the
or any of your own favorite games uh do
share in the comments and i will look
into them tomorrow and sorry about a bit
of a longer video uh but we did cover
three games so uh you know what are you
gonna do
uh once again really hope you guys
enjoyed it uh very much uh uh you know
uh
appreciating both uh prague and the
magnus for playing such incredible chess
and for entertaining us i would like to
thank brian enriquez
krishna kumar john anderson lucian rosa
and aksha pandit for your contribution
to my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon uh
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and we are finally going to
show that wild wild game between
stockfish and chess master the grand
master edition uh thank you all i will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day